hey folks Chris waters here with Tom
McShay to talk about some breaking news
this Monday Gears of War has been sold
by Epic Games to Microsoft so now the
exclusive publisher of Gears of War just
owns the whole thing they own the games
that the past games the future games the
entertainment prop experiences toys
merchandise the whole package baby bib
is now in Microsoft's courts so what do
you think Tom what's up this well this
is a real kick to my anticipation junk
wasn't it why like it's like cuz black
tusk was founded in Vancouver one of
those beautiful cities in the world to
make new games new experiences we've
never seen before in fact on their
founding one of the founders quoted was
we are working on Microsoft's next big
entertainment franchise we're not
working on an existing franchise we're
looking to build the next halo so that's
not happening now now that they're just
bringing back the pony and it's like
gears is not on its way up it's on its
way down ya head freash you know strong
trilogy and then gears of war judgment
kind of not a lot of excitement for that
that sort of felt like tacked on
definitely feels like it was sort of
contained within the previous console
generation but got a whole new studio
working on it now they've got a ton of
developers already hired there in
Vancouver so new gears is coming what
what do you think is going to be well
it's it's going to be gears like years
is a it's not the most flexible
franchise like it's about big dudes with
cover and fighting big dudes with guns
like it isn't I don't think you're gonna
see it have like the expansive growth
you couldn't other genres okay or other
oh their franchises I think we're gonna
see a little bit more the same like they
try to mix up the storytelling the
judgment but I think we know what gears
is don't we I mean certainly
mechanically it has so much of that game
is down to the feel of the shooting in
the movement and the characters and so
we're definitely to see something
similar to that I guess you know as a
fan I'm wondering the locust war stuff
is sort of already run its course in the
pats console generation so maybe there's
the pendulum Wars which are actually
human on human conflict that tore that
planet apart before
emergence day so maybe we'll see some of
that but you also mentioned something
earlier a Gears of War HD possibly being
in the memory yet well I imagine we're
going to see a remake of the original
gears this year just to keep gears fresh
in people's minds kind of like a halo
combat evolved anniversary yeah I but I
kind of feel bad for black bucket us cuz
I don't know if the people who signed up
their new they are going to be making a
Gears it's certain all over their
website and even on that there's a lead
writer position listed that is helping
to work it says who can help us bring
Microsoft's next big I life so clearly
that studios you know mantra good is
could be shifted because now they're
working on old IP we talked about what
games we might see we gonna hear some
announcements this year you think we
might see a teaser I mean I think halo 5
is going to come out in September so
that'll be the big one and that's
another studio that was like a brand-new
studio form to make someone else's
leftover since the bungee moved on to
bigger and better thing thats right
maralell there of the developers who you
know the the franchise that minted them
and Microsoft you know made their
reputations made tons of money now being
shuffled back to Microsoft while they go
on to do other stuff Epic Games in this
case they're living on fortnight which
is their cooperative sandbox survival
game for the pc and they've also got
other things in the works there but they
haven't enough i'm out of that yet I
know this is because I used to love
gears but it just it feels like they're
kind of bringing back the band and it's
like I kind of want to see something
else so this is really disappointing for
me because I was I was excited about
black dust I want to see what they could
do they were gonna come up with yeah I
was hoping would be like the equivalent
of like the order who's making that in
that new exciting game for playstation 4
I was hoping it was like that's we'd see
mm-hmm but instead of our gonna see more
Marcus Fenix hello Marcus well let us
know what you folks think about gears
are you excited that it's gonna have new
life on the xbox one or are you like Tom
and just kind of all right I understand
your apathy Tom I'm interested to see
where it goes let us know what you think
in the comments below and thanks for
watching